[Musique]
en devenant Ambassadrice itinérante de l'UNICEF,
je partage le titre avec l'une de mes héroïnes,
feu Audrey Hepburn, qui a
dit un jour qu'en vieillissant, vous découvrirez
que vous avez deux mains, une pour aider les
autres et une pour vous aider vous-même et
c'est exactement  ce que j'ai l'intention de faire
[Musique]
mon père m'a vraiment motivé à le faire comme
dans le premier comme il l'a dit je pense que
tu serais vraiment drôle et comme tu
peux faire comme les comédies
[Musique]
J'entre dans des choses étranges et je pensais que je
Je ne vais vraiment PAS comprendre cela, je veux dire
qu'il y a tellement de 306 filles talentueuses qui ont
auditionné pour onze
[Musique]
c'est un tel honneur d'être ici ce soir pour
aider à célébrer le 70e anniversaire de l'UNICEF
[Musique]
c'est incroyable, très amusant et incroyable et un
grand  Honneur pour moi
[Musique],
vous savez, écoutez ce que tout le monde dit
parce qu'en fin de compte, c'est
leur problème auquel ils traitent
clairement, ils en ont certains, vous savez
quelque chose qui se passe avec eux et
ils ne sont juste pas sûrs et ça va
parce que  utiliser chaque adolescent n'est pas sûr, mais je
pense qu'il est juste important de s'élever
au-dessus de cela, vous savez que vous connaissez votre valeur et
et soyez simplement vous-même et continuez à être
vous-même et ne laissez personne changer
cela
[Musique
] c'était un grand moment pour moi tout entier
famille nous nous sommes tous effondrés et puis nous sommes
tous retournés à notre époque il n'y avait rien de
vraiment spécial mais c'était incroyable
[Musique]
Je parlerai pour les millions d'
enfants et de jeunes dont les voix
ont été réduites au silence depuis trop
longtemps  sûr que les enfants et les jeunes
connaissent leurs droits et je ferai
tout mon possible pour leur donner les moyens d'être
le changement qu'ils veulent voir dans le monde